[Music]
[Applause]
great it's crazy now this is the way
this is the way I learn about the
solutions it's your personal touch it's
my personal touch here's how the survey
works we ask three celebrities to
complete a phrase our first phrase was
if I'm elected this fall it means
there's going to be more Hillary Clinton
said women in high office John Kasich
said moderates in the Republican Party
Donald Trump said Americans in Canada I
wish people would stop confusing me for
Josh GAD said Jonah Hill Rhetta said
Viola Davis Johnny Depp said a Gypsys
yard sale Beyonce's lemonade has proven
Josh Groban said the art of the
full-length album is alive and well Maya
Rudolph said Beyonce is today's most
vital pop music artist jay-z said the
couch in the den is surprisingly
comfortable to sleep
the best the best piece of advice my
father ever gave me was Timothy Olyphant
said save your money for a rainy day
Emily Blunt said always pursue your
dreams Larry King said don't throw your
spear until the mastodon he's hundreds
of thousands of years old right right
will furrow walking away from a
controversial portrayal of Ronald Reagan
is Edward Norton said probably the right
thing to do Charlie Sheen said happening
because his publicists are freaking out
Conan O'Brien said giving me second
thoughts about starring in the upcoming
gala
why did I write a survey question and
mail it to myself because it's a good
reason to say gay Nixon exactly I wish I
had more time to John Krasinski said
travel with my wife Jennifer Aniston
said read fiction tone loke said steal
celebrities mail and fill out their
surveys yeah yeah it's hard to accept
that I've been mathematically eliminated
from Ted Cruz said the Republican
nomination Bernie Sanders said the
Democratic nomination Axl Rose said
tinder I think that might be me actually
that's that's you with a muffin on your
head
[Applause]
with a freshly baked muffin
my hairstyle could be described as John
Cena said military Miley Cyrus said
retro Punk Bernie Sanders said man
falling out of an airplane as the spouse
of a presidential candidate I can assure
you that Heidi Cruz said Ted is a
devoted husband and father Bill Clinton
said Hillary is the most qualified
candidate Melania Trump said sometimes
when he's lying on top of me I lose
count of the ceiling tile
a lot of emotions swirling through this
crowd right yeah
anger joy hey and finally this month I'm
looking forward to meeting Barack Obama
said the Prime Minister of Japan Donald
Trump said Indiana Governor Mike Pence
former House Speaker Dennis Hastert said
subway spokesman Jared Fogle
[Applause]
you